in a previous video we figured out a way
to multiply a two digit number times a
one digit number what we did is we broke
up the two digit numbers in terms of its
place value so the three here in the
tens place that's three tens this is
seven ones so we viewed 37 sixes as the
same thing as
30 sixes three tens times six
plus
seven sixes seven times six and then we
added those together to get a total of
two hundred and twenty two
what we'll try in this video is now see
what happens if we try to do two digits
times two digits so let's try to tackle
37
37 instead of six let's multiply that
times 26. so we're trying to figure out
37 26s is one way to think about it so
pause this video and see if you can
tackle that and see if you could maybe
use a similar method to what we used
before
well one way to think about it is you
could view this as 37 26s or you could
view this as 37 sixes plus 37 20s
so first we can do the 37 60s and 37
sixes which is exactly what we did over
here we said hey that's the same thing
and we could do it in either order we
could say hey let's first think about 30
sixes so we're going to multiply 30
times 6. 36's is 180. so that right over
there is 3 tens
3 tens times 6
and then we could think about
the 7 ones times 6
and so that's going to be 42
that's the 7
ones
times 6 or the 7 6's and then we can do
the same thing with the twenties we
could say hey
what are three tens
what are thirty twenties going to be so
let's write that over here or you could
say what are three tens times two tens
well that would be six
times 10 times 10. so let me write this
down this is 3
tens
times 2 tens that's what we're going to
do now
times 2
tens and that's the same thing as which
is equal to 30 times 20 which is the
same thing as 3 times 2 times 10 times
10 well that's going to be 600 so we
could write that here
600 and just be very clear we've already
thought about 37 sixes that's these two
numbers up here we have to add that we
still have to add them but now we're
thinking about 37 20s so first we
thought about 30 20s which is 600 and
now we could think about seven
20s
so 7 20s
is going to be 7 times 2 is 14 so 7
times 20 is 140. so i'll write that
right over here
140
to be clear this is 7 ones
times
2 tens or seven twenties and now we can
add it all together
to get what the total would be so we in
total we have and that's why it's useful
to have everything stacked by their
place value we could look at the ones
place and we say okay we only have a
total of two ones here so i'll put a two
there
now let's see tens we have eight tens
plus four tens is twelve tens plus
another four tens is sixteen tens
sixteen tens we can also break up as one
hundred and six tens so we could write
the six tens here and then put the that
hundred up here so one hundred plus
another hundred is two hundred
plus
six hundreds is eight hundreds plus one
more hundred is nine hundreds
and so there you have it this is equal
to 962. i really want you to understand
what we just did it might look a little
bit complicated but first we thought
about what is 37 sixes that's where we
got these numbers from and that's what
we had done in a previous video and then
we just thought about well what is 37 20
is going to be and that's where these
numbers came from and actually let me
write that down this whole thing that
i'm circling in orange that is 37
sixes or let me yeah i'll write it i'll
write it as 37 times 6 and then this is
37 20s so 37 times 20.
so if it's not obvious pause the video
or after this video reflect on this why
this works try it with other numbers
because if you really understand this
then your multiplication life and
actually your mathematical lives in your
future will only become more and more
intuitive